il y a dans votre attitude comme vous le
démontrez à chaque conseil de Paris
d'ailleurs votre désinvolture c'est la
même d'ailleurs qui vous coûte très cher
si l'on peut dire dans le cadre de votre
voyage à Libye à Tahiti dont on apprend
encore ce matin que vous avez bénéficier
d'un hélicoptère alors même que vous
faisiez croire que vous étiez en train
de faire du vélo sur une piste cyclable
parisienne si vous trouvez trace d'un
hélicoptère prévenez-moi parce que je je
je n'en ai pas vu trace vous dire aussi
que vos insinuations vos attaques
permanentes vous avez convoqué la presse
pour queil y ait un show voilà vous êtes
messieurs mesdames les journalistes
convoqués au Dati show depuis ce matin
je reçois des messages alors alors alors
le Dati show mais le Dati show c'est un
peu calmé parce que parce que Madame
daty certes elle est présidente d'un
groupe qui a une vision radicalement
différente de la nôtre ellete pas
l'écologie elle porte pas le social et
évidemment évidemment et et c'est c'est
respectable je respecte je respecte je
respecte tout à fait parce que la beauté
de la démocratie c'est qu'il y ait des
différences des différences et des
projets qui s'affrontent
démocratiquement et ensuite les
électeurs tranche en l'occurrence ça
fait quand même depuis 20 ans qu'il
tranchent en dehors de ce que vous leur
proposez